So the objectives of this specific lesson is that I'm going to
introduce you to the concept of point processes.
That is, how do you basically use pixel values themselves and
use them in computations?
We will use this to do addition and subtraction of images but it can be used to
doing any other kinds of mathematical operations like multiplication.
I'm going to use this also concept to introduce the concept of alpha values and
alpha blending.
And how can we use some different types of simple image processing methods.
And while we have talked about image histograms in the previous lecture,
in this lecture I'm going, I'm going to give you a much better handle on how we
can use image histograms to look at the statistics of images and
how we can use them in different methods of computer vision and image processing